[Music]
on this Sunday night more tragedy from
Hamas atrocities another Canadian
confirmed dead after the horrific
attacks on Israel we speak with his
mother in a global news exclusive the
heartbreaking final messages between
them Mommy what's happening mommy come
on what's what's going on Mommy what's
happening under bombardment and without
Aid gaza's worsening humanitarian crisis
at the same time we have staff who
foreign shelters who are not safe it's
very distressing the death and
Desperation among civilians as Israel's
military prepares a major
Onslaught plus thousands of Canadians in
the region still at risk the
increasingly complicated task of getting
them
out global national with far Asser
reporting Tonight Eric
senson good evening and thanks for
joining us with each passing hour the
world is waiting for Israel's next move
on Sunday more Israeli army tanks
gathered on the border with Gaza as
Israeli troops for the moment hold their
ground before an expected allout assault
Israel's wartime government held its
first meeting prime minister Benjamin
Netanyahu called it a show of unity
within Israel to annihilate
Hamas what is not on hold is the
humanitarian crisis in Gaza gazans
continue to make their way south to what
they hope is safety but in reality it is
a region unable to provide even basic
necessities what adds to the desperation
and anger is a convoy of humanitarian
Aid on the Egyptian side of the border
at Rafa that cannot get across there are
conflicting accounts that Hamas or
Israeli air strikes are blocking the
Border but whatever the reason that
border is closed and Canadians in Gaza
cannot get out we'll have more on that
in a moment but we begin tonight with
news that a fifth Canadian has been
identified among those killed in the
attack by Hamas in Israel a week ago
Global's Jeff simple spoke exclusively
with his mother today and he joins us
now Jeff such Dreadful news Eric Neta
Epstein was a skilled soccer player
Gardener who loved to brew his own beer
and would put a Canadian map belief on
the label the 21-year-old is now the
latest Canadian to be identified as a
victim of
Hamas this small tight-knit Israeli
community of kafar aah was one of the
first to be attacked by Hamas so when
residents started hearing gunshots in
the distance they had no idea what was
coming it was weird we didn't we didn't
really understand what was going on
aella chahar Epstein is Israeli Canadian
her family originally from Montreal but
she grew up here near the Gaza border
and is used to hearing the occasional
air raid siren warning of a possible
incoming rocket strike we know the drill
very well when the alarm goes off we go
into the safe room in the safe room she
started messaging her extended family
members in the community including her
21-year-old son Netta who lived in an
apartment with his fiance nearby so it
starts at 7:55 aella showed us her chat
history from that morning she asked her
son to phone her mommy I can't call you
okay sweetheart when you can then aella
received a message that her
mother-in-law had been hurt she ran over
to their house down the street to find
her mother-in-law shot to death the
terorists were there all over they were
killing people in neighbor houses
there's yelling in Arabic and there's
shooting and there's there's mayham
outside she ran into the safe room and
messaged her son Neta again and now I'm
asking him is are they shooting in your
neighborhood yes and there's yelling in
Hebrew and there's massive shooting and
there's a car that's beeping all the
time and I don't understand what's going
on they're out of my they're outside my
apartment so I write to him okay my
sweetheart just hold youran tightly I
love you and he sent me this big hearts
the last message I have from him is um
mommy they're here Hamas gunman broke
into netta's apartment where he and his
fiance iren were hiding then they threw
a grenade very close to where she was
and he
Neta um jumped on it uh to protect her
the grenade detonated netta's fiance
remained hidden and thankfully the
gunman never saw her and she managed to
escape over a week later crews are still
recovering the Dead from the community
some of the bodies are rigged with
explosives then Sunday morning the
family finally received confirmation
Netta did not survive nor did three
other members of their extended family
we were the
targets we civilians
this funeral held for another Israeli
Canadian adiv Vel kapon the 33y old
mother of two young children killed
defending her family she saved her
father she saved her children she fought
till the last moment this small
community population around 700 lost
more than 50 people more than a dozen
others from here are missing and
presumed Hamas hostages Israel's
President says they found Hamas
militants carrying these Jihad handbooks
with instructions on how to kill torture
and kidnap the people that live on our
kibuts are peaceloving people
that held hold their hands out for peace
with the other
side and what has been done to us is
Slaughter there's growing speculation
here that the military is wor working to
rescue those Israeli hostages before
launching its ground assault in Gaza a
military spokesperson told me today that
the troops are ready to go and waiting
for the government to make the call
Eric Jeff simple in Jerusalem thank you
Jeff as the humanitarian crisis grows in
Gaza Israel says it is restarting the
water supply to parts of Southern Gaza
it comes amid diplomatic pressure from
the US the Israelis had cut off water
electricity and food to Gaza Following
last weekend's surprise attack and now a
ground assault is imminent crystal
ganing is following the developments
from Jerusalem tonight and a warning
some of the details in her story are
disturbing Crystal Eric un Aid agencies
are deeply concerned about the spiraling
humanitarian situation in Gaza the
relief and works Agency for Palestine
refugees called the situation bone
chilling saying it is on the brink of
collapse and that was on
Friday I cream these are ice cream
freezers says Dr Yasser Ali ice cream
freezers containing the bodies of the
dead he says they're in such gruesome
State they haven't been
identified seemingly Relentless strikes
on Gaza means there's little time for
people to dig out loved ones trapped
under the rubble before another round of
attacks begin and another run for help
to a hospital that may or may not have
supplies or power the Gaza Health
Ministry says more than 2600 people have
lost their lives in the past week that
number continues to climb doctors have
been warning of the horrific conditions
in hospitals too many patients too few
doctors and not enough medical
supplies Global News has been speaking
with Dr gassi abua at the main facility
in Gaza he shared this audio message
update with us on Sunday the catastrophe
in the hospital is just waiting to
happen there are tens of thousands of
people blop salt refuge in the
corridors in the doorways in the
stairwell everywhere everywhere you can
imagine every
corner and with the hygiene and with the
unseasonably warm weather this is a tyus
or chera epidemic waiting to happen
before Israel declared war vowing to
eliminate Hamas from Gaza there was a
high level of poverty and hunger in The
Enclave now those with the world food
program says even their staff need help
we have staff who who are in shelters
who are not safe who call us and say hey
can can the bakeries that give food to
the idps can can they also give us some
food humanitarian corridors are being
negotiated but so far Aid is not getting
in many are leaving what little they
have in the north following Israel's
warnings and heading south for their own
protection I try to evacuate my house
we've been working with Aziz aloho in
Gaza he's finally been able to to move
his family a bit further south but he
did not find safety these are three
houses targeted by
Israeli forces occupation forces not
less than 100 uh person under this uh
destruction civilians are never supposed
to be Targets in war the UN has been
calling for their protection agencies
under the international Banner are
working together and are hopeful they'll
be able to move in Supply
soon we call for that unimpeded access
because we need these three priorities
and and supplies and the medical
supplies the water and the food that's
our priority as a as a community US
Secretary of State Anthony blinkin will
be back here in Israel Monday the hope
is that his Swift return will mean good
news for those stuck and suffering in
Gaza Eric thanks Crystal Crystal Gan
saying in Jerusalem more than 1,000
Canadians have now fled from Tel Aviv
aboard military planes sent from Ottawa
but there are still thousands more
seeking help Canadians and their
families stranded in both Israeli and
Palestinian territory as the conflict
escalates our McKenzie gray brings us
the latest on the federal government's
response from Parliament
Hill Eric as the situation becomes
increasingly dire in Gaza the number of
Canadians looking for help out has
doubled to 300 we were hoping to have an
opportunity for an exit through Rafa on
Saturday which sadly did not
materialize that Crossing is between
Gaza and Egypt the only way out of the
Palestinian territory there's no new
timeline for a potential evacuation and
only a partial explanation as to why no
one was allowed to leave Saturday Hamas
is probably playing some obstruction
inside of Gaza as well and uh is in some
cases uh preventing uh the the movement
of some individuals in inside Gaza
hamas's instructions conflicting with
Israeli orders the IDF telling over a
million people in Northern Gaza to flee
south or get caught up in a potential
ground Invasion to help the displaced
the Canadian government has pledged 10
million in aid but no key supplies like
water food or medicine have made it into
Gaza but if they do Canadian officials
say they won't go to Hamas we only deal
with trusted credible partners that are
on the
ground enhanced diligence also advised
to the 14,500 Canadians currently in
Lebanon Canadians who are already in
Lebanon should think about whether you
really need to be there and if you don't
need to be there you should consider
leaving while commercial means are still
available the federal government hoping
to avoid a similar scene from when
Lebanese military group Hezbollah and
Israel were at War back in 2006 Ottawa
sent cruise ships and planes to evacuate
thousands of
Canadians similar to what's happening
now in Tel Aviv where an additional 2300
Canadians want help to get out our
Bridge from uh from Tel Aviv tson is
continuing uh as I said today two
flights occurred today uh two more are
scheduled for tomorrow there is one
positive the Israeli government has
given permission for approximately 250
Canadians to leave the West Bank but
Global Affairs is still waiting on
approval from Jordan to let those
Canadians cross into their territory
Eric thanks McKenzie McKenzie gray in
Ottawa
free free free
Palestine hundreds of people gathered on
Parliament Hill for a pro Palestinian
March this afternoon signs reading Stop
The Siege on Gaza and justice for
Palestine with demonstrators chanting
end the occupation now as they made
their way to the Israeli
Embassy a lot of people have children on
both sides and this needs to stop there
needs to be
peace just a few hours later in the same
location hundreds of marching in support
of Israel many can be seen wearing
Israeli flags as capes and others
holding posters with photos of those
missing while the crowd chants bring
them
home it's been nearly 72 hours since
people in Northern Gaza were given a
day's warning to clear out and move
South but Israel has still not invaded
joining us now is Mercedes Stevenson
Mercedes what do you make of the
apparent
delay Eric I haven't been surprised by
the delay based on what Israeli and
Canadian National Security sources been
saying for the Israelis this isn't about
a ticking clock it's about having the
conditions in place to win what could be
a multi-front war one of the most
important conditions is accurate
intelligence after suffering such a
massive intelligence failure that
allowed the attack to happen there has
been extensive Intel Gathering underway
including through Special Forces raids
into Gaza those special forces operators
are looking for information about
hostages who may have ordered the
attacks and what kinds of weapons Hamas
might have sources have told me that
Hamas is believed to be sitting on a
much larger and more sophisticated
weapons cache than was previously
assumed and they are ready to fight the
IDF needs as much information as
possible on where the hostages might be
being held as well so they can deal with
any potential booby traps that could be
designed to kill them or Israeli troops
during a rescue some American
Publications have stated that weather
may also be a factor the IDF has a
greater Advantage with clear skies for
their drones and
ples Mercedes with skirmishes overnight
on Israel's northern border is there a
risk of this
spreading that's also part of what's
taking time Eric the IDF has to figure
out how to split its troops in case
there is a two-front war one with Hamas
in Gaza and another potentially with
Hezbollah which is located across its
northern border with Lebanon Hezbollah
is much bigger much better armed much
more sophisticated and much more deadly
than Hamas if if Iran is backing
Hezbollah and Hamas in these fights
Israel will be taking on an enemy with
Deep Pockets and heavy weapons then
there's the practicalities that have
been taking time many of the reservists
who've been called up have civilian jobs
they need to be armed get up to speed on
the training and moved into place Israel
has also used this time to soften its
Target through the blockade of food
water and humanitarian Aid to Gaza
turning off the power leaving chaos and
making it difficult for the enemy to
communicate in the hopes of weakening
them but that also has the effect of
harming civilian and that creates a
deadline for international support for
Israel there's also an element of
psychology here the anticipatory anxiety
of waiting to be attacked when Israel
moves it will be sudden and aggressive
but it won't be determined by any
publicly announced
deadlines Mercedes Stevenson in Ottawa
thank you getting more people out of
danger coming up American diplomatic
efforts to secure more aid for
Gaza
getting more than a million people
including hundreds of Canadians and
Americans out of Harm's Way in Gaza is a
Herculean task today US Secretary of
State Anthony blinkin said Egypt's Rafa
border crossing will reopen blinkin says
Arab states do not want the crisis to
spark a wider regional conflict Joel
senik reports life-saving supplies
stalled at the border of Egypt and Gaza
more than 100 trucks filled with food
clothes and Medicine unable to cross
America's top Diplomat is working to
open up the passage as he remains in the
Middle East we're determined to do
everything we can to address the needs
of people in Gaza uh civilians should
not have to suffer for hamas's
atrocities US Secretary of State Anthony
blinkin says addressing the humanitarian
crisis is a primary goal of his
diplomatic Mission President Joe Biden
reaffirming that on social media saying
America is working to ensure supplies
reach civilians in Gaza as troops
prepare for a ground offensive in the
region the way that Israel does this
matters uh needs to do it in a way that
affirms uh the shared values that we
have for human life and human dignity
officials are working to open up the
Crossing in the opposite direction as
well hundreds of Canadians and Americans
are currently in Gaza hoping to travel
into Egypt before the ground battle
begins the US told its citizens to be
near the border for a possible reopening
this weekend which never happened Hamas
has intervened in some cases uh to make
it hard for uh Palestinians Palestinian
Americans and and others to be able TR
to travel to the border crossing and get
through the Border crisis is turning
into a complicated and pivotal part of
the ongoing conflict secretary blinkin
says he's working to broker a deal to
move both Aid and people he's confident
a solution can be reached as he now
plans to travel back to Israel for more
diplomatic talks on Monday Joel senic
Global News
Washington still ahead what's at stake
for Poland in its crucial
[Music]
election more anguish in Afghanistan
after another powerful earthquake hit
the country's Western harat Province the
6.3 magnitude Quake flattened entire
Villages hundreds of people people are
feared dead harat has been hammered by a
series of earthquakes in recent days
killing at least 1,000 people in the war
battered
country people in Poland went to the
polls for their election today and the
country's opposition leader and the
outgoing prime minister are both
claiming Victory exit polls suggest the
ruling Law And Justice party won the
most votes yet the country's Coalition
combinations May favor opposition
parties as Redmond Shannon reports with
implications for the war in Ukraine and
European Unity today's vote is being
called Poland's most important in
decades democracy has won says polish
opposition leader Donald Tusk after exit
polls appeared to give his party group
and potential Coalition Partners the
upper
[Applause]
hand while Yos kachinski of the ruling
Law And Justice party insists nothing
has been decided yet despite losing his
parliamentary majority
like so many elections these days
polands was fought on the culture wars
migration abortion and lgbtq2 rights but
polls also faced a more fundamental
choice just 32 years since its first
postcommunist
election the law and Justice party is
socially conservative but leans left on
public spending the European Union has
withheld funds to Poland over concerns
about changes to the country's Judicial
System under the leadership of outgoing
prime minister Matos morvi media Freedom
has been under scrutiny too Poland is a
trend
Setter in Europe it was Trend Setter
towards democracy and EU enlargement uh
30 years ago and now the pendum of
History turn into the opposite direction
in the leadup to the election Poland has
threatened to stop sending arms to to
its Ally and neighbor Ukraine in a
dispute over grain
Imports Tusk is a pro-european former
prime minister he told voters he will
reverse the government's reforms to
protect Poland's democracy we can be
different but we have to be one and uh
I'm fed up with the hatred the final
outcome however could be decided by the
exact number of seats won by the smaller
parties Coalition negotiations could
take weeks weeks before a government is
formed Redmond Shannon Global News
[Music]
London next people around the world pay
tribute to the victims of the violence
between Israel and
[Music]
Hamas the fighting in the Middle East
could enter a new phase at any moment
thousands have already died in both
Israel and Gaza and people are wondering
when the violence will
end
tonight we leave you with vigils from
around the world honoring the victims of
this brutal
conflict thank you for
[Music]
watching
look
[Music]